Eric Velasquez illustrator of the new
biography champion it chronicles Ali's
life from his childhood in Louisville
Kentucky through his controversial
boxing career and finally his ongoing
battle with Parkinson's disease during
the talk mr. Velasquez also details the
process of illustrating books for young
adults it's an hour and 15 minutes good
morning my name is mr. Corsetti for
those of you that don't know me and
first I want to take the opportunity to
welcome you all and this morning I own a
grammar school is fortunate enough to
have with us mr. Eric Velazquez the
illustrator of champion the story of
Muhammad Ali written by Jim Haskins he's
also the illustrator of such books as
piano man the sound that jazz makes and
grandmas records which was his first
book that he authored so without further
ado please give a warm round of applause
to mr. Eric Velazquez
thank you thank you and good morning and
it's nice to be here at the Iona Grammar
School okay before I tell you about
champion I'd like to tell you a little
about myself
both my parents come from the island of
Puerto Rico and that's where and they
settled in Spanish Harlem where I was
born although my parents both English
and work watched english-speaking
television at home we spoke Spanish and
as a result I spoke Spanish until the
age of five in order to get me ready for
school my mother brought home picture
books which he would read to me and soon
I discovered that you could sometimes
look at the pictures and tell what the
story was by just looking at the images
this was like magic to me and my
fascination with illustration began at
that point soon I began creating my own
picture books I would draw my own little
stories based on the books and at about
the age of 10 or so we moved to Harlem
which was about five blocks away from
Spanish Harlem but it's a world apart so
around that time as I I discovered comic
books now as I mentioned earlier I just
start speaking English at a late age so
as a result my reading levels were
always low so as I continued to read
comic books mom like one summer in
particular my reading levels jumped to
grades so when I took the reading
comprehension test in school the
teachers thought that I might have been
cheating so they gave me the test a
second time and of course I said I
scored higher the second time around as
it was as a result comic books became a
big part of my life I began reading them
a lot and I started to draw my own based
on drunk draw my own stories based on my
friends and movies that my father would
take me to I just was you know
having a ball at that point up until the
time I was a senior in high school I
wanted to be a comic book artist but
when I was a senior that's when I was
introduced to oil painting at the high
school of art designed by two wonderful
teachers max Ginsberg and Aaron Erwin
greenberg I then attended college at the
School of Visual Arts where I continue
to develop my painting technique I began
my career as an illustrator right after
receiving my BFA from the School of
Visual Arts and for the first 12 years
of my career I concentrated mostly on
doing book covers in chapter books then
I got a chance to illustrate my first
picture book the piano man for Walker
and company the experience of creating
the images for the piano man reminded me
of my childhood when I would create my
own comic books I loved it so around
after after completing my fourth picture
book
grandma's records which I wrote and is
based on my summers with my grandmother
in Spanish Harlem walking company asked
me if I would be interested in
illustrating champion the story of
Muhammad Ali I immediately became
excited at the idea of illustrating the
life of a real live hero once I heard
that the text was being written by Jim
Hoskins I jumped to say yes at the time
my editors Emily Easton and Tim travel
Eenie were were not aware that I had
always admired Muhammad Ali his razzle
dazzle style of boxing was magical to me
but however what impressed me most about
his career was that at the height he was
the heavyweight champion of the world
and had given up his title because of
his beliefs in opposition to the draft
to the war in Vietnam Ali would be
willing to go to jail rather than
compromise his belief as I began to work
on this project one of my biggest
challenges that I faced was that
Mohammed Ali's career has been still
documented so well known by so many fans
especially fans like my father and guys
like my father very unforgiving if the
details are not correct when they read
something as particularly about things
that they know it became essential that
every detail in Ali's life and fighting
our career be authentic my dad has
always has always been a boxing fan so
from an early age I was familiar with
most boxers including Muhammad Ali and
although I'm a little too young to
remember the first Cassius Clay versus
Sonny Liston fight I remember going to
my elementary school library to find
pictures of up the fight that my dad
called one of the greatest fights he had
ever seen in his life I remember finding
the book with the photos in it and
seeing the photos of Ali proclaiming
himself the king of the world after he
after he beat Sonny Liston and the
photos seemed frightening and chaotic
but I couldn't stop looking at them I
was captivated more than thirty years
later I would be looking at the very
same photos as part of my research for
this project I did more research for
this book than any other I borrowed
photos from the New York Public Library
picture collection I purchased six books
on Muhammad Ali prior to starting the
project I read the book king of the
world
by David Remnick which my editor Tim
travel Eenie sent me along with a video
called fighter of the century I also
watched the film the greatest starring
Muhammad Ali the Fox film
Ali an American Hero not to mention the
documentaries when we were Kings Ali
versus Frazier in addition to the hours
of fight footage that I taped off at
ESPN that I ran continuously in my
studio while working on this project
reference is something you can never
have too much of when you're working on
these
oh and incidentally the Will Smith movie
Ally was still in production while I was
working on this so I didn't have the
opportunity to see that so before we go
any further now I think at this point
I'd like to show you how everything gets
started this is the original manuscript
that I received from Tim my editor which
this is how everything starts
illustrators received the manuscript and
as you can see is just words on a page
and is our responsibility to put the
pictures to the words so after reading
the manuscript a couple of times I start
making little thumbnail sketches similar
to these here makeup I make hundreds of
sketches like this which kind of mapped
away for me later on as I start
developing the story visually from that
point I take my favorite thumbnail
sketches and I create this which is
called a book dummy
now in the book dummy what I do is I
take the manuscript I cut it up
sometimes I blow up the words to suit my
needs and I paste them down and I draw
out what you know the image is the way I
want them to be presented in the final
and sometimes there it changes from this
point to the finish but sometimes
they're pretty faithful as you can see
by just comparing to the board but this
is probably the most fun for me
because it's just like when I used to do
my comic books at home and any one of
you that are interested in making your
own books at home this is very simple to
do you just take paper and you fold it
pasted it together take your words you
cut it out paste it down and you're
telling a story and this is my dummy
book as you can see there's the prayer
scene as you'll see later in my slide
presentation how close this is from like
the initial idea to the finish
and then there are other times where the
ideas just didn't work like for instance
there's this scene which my editor felt
was not appropriate for this project so
it was changed and actually when I
changed it it was a better image so my
editor was right okay so after the dummy
is done
I am I draw the the pieces up on a large
sheet of paper and prior to painting I
do these color sketches and the purpose
of the color sketch is to make sure that
the colors all worked well together and
to avoid any surprises later and it also
cuts down on time but the color sketch
is also fun to do that's the color
sketch for the cover which you see there
done on tracing paper there's a color
sketch for every page in the book so um
we'll turn now to the slides okay before
I get started I draw out everything on a
large sheet of paper like I mentioned
and it looks something like this this is
the cover before I started to paint on
it I draw it out on pencil in pencil on
watercolor paper a heavy weight
watercolor paper that's a picture of me
working in my studio that my wife took
just to give you guys an idea you know
what my studio looks like and what I
look like while I'm working that's my
mall stick the image that is on the on
the easel is from my book grandma's
records that I did prior to doing the
champion book that's my palette that
drawer contains I don't know hundreds of
tubes of paint and I lay them out in no
particular order in my on my palette but
by mixing the colors together I can
create any color that I want and you can
also see my brushes that's just a
portion of the brushes I own hundreds
and hundreds of brushes but
that's my palate okay this is the image
for the endpapers and this is what it
looked like before I painted it as well
okay and this is what the finished
looked like the end papers for the end
papers I wanted something that just
represented maybe an old boxing gym
maybe the same gym where Muhammad Ali
used to practice before his big fight
with Sonny Liston for the championship
of the world so I wanted the poster to
kind of echo the idea of the fight
that's coming that's coming in the book
as you read the book and the gloves you
know baby represent you know the old
pair glove did MA the same clothes that
Muhammad Ali used to fight Sonny Liston
actually those are the I use photos of
the ax fight so that's the color of the
gloves that he did fight Sonny Liston
win okay okay that's the title page of
the book and that for here I had to do
impart as part of my research the trunks
that Ali used when he was still called
Cassius Clay when he fought Sonny Liston
were those trunks right there with the
black band and the the red stripe down
the side I had to look through tons of
reference to find the color reference
since back then most of the photographs
were in black and white okay this is the
first image of the book where Ali is
travelling in a plane and he's looking
out and realizes that he's probably the
most famous man in the world at this
point so I always like the images of
like planes as they soar by and it just
seemed you know appropriate that you
know Ali is riding in this plane and
he's looking out at the whole world
realizing that you know he is at this
point the most famous man in the world
this is the one of the first images in
the book where you see his mother and
father this there's no existing photo
like this so what I had to do is I had
to find photos of
Mohammed Ali's mother and father and his
brother Rahman or at this time Rudi
and I put it together by just using the
different pieces of reference like a
family portrait of the affor and then
for the image down at the at the bottom
I had to find a model to be Muhammad Ali
at about the age of 12 or so so my
nephew Andy looked a little like
Muhammad Ali seemed to be like the
perfect model this is once again just as
near the beginning of the story where
Ali is used to race the bus to school
and just showing the people on the
street the bus the busses in lieu old
Louisville
I used myself as one of the models for
the people on the street and I figured
well you have my wife next to me I try
to always make a cameo appearance in all
my books and this is it for me in this
book okay this is Ali as a young very
young boxer when he's introduced to
boxing by a policeman that ran the P al
tal Athletic League you'll learn more of
this as as we read the story later but I
wanted to focus on my nephew Andy who I
gave him a pair of boxing gloves and
asked him to pose as Muhammad Ali first
of all I was surprised that he even knew
Muhammad Ali was and once he put on the
boxing gloves he he became Ali he
started to trash-talking and he I was so
blown away by the fact that he
understood who Ali was and that he was
able to step into the character over the
years I've used family members many
times as models and I'm always so
surprised and touched by the fact that
they always are able to step up to the
plate and deliver and you know Andy just
you know he he knocked the ball out of
the park for me down below we have ollie
he's getting a little older and he's
training now for the Olympics this is
the Olympic page as I call it with the
medal I had to research the medal the
color for the trunks and the tank top I
had to do a lot of reference for that
once again because a lot of the other
reference materials in black and white I
had to find everything in all the color
photos for you know to get the colors
just right and that's what he returns
home his mom and his dad and his brother
awaiting for him awaiting him rather
this is when Ali or at this point still
Cassius Clay signs with the Phoenix
group the group of investors Louisville
investors that that support his career
early on and I also found a photo of his
tour bus which I always found very
interesting because of all the colors
there so I put that in there as well and
this is the first fight with Sonny
Liston now this was an opportunity for
me to really combine my love of comic
books with the picture books that I'm
doing this was a lot of fun for me I
love the paneling and this is like based
on the photos that I did see when I was
about eight years old or so in the
elementary school library of him
fighting Sonny Liston and then did the
chaotic scene and after the fight that
you know had been mesmerised as a child
and I really wanted to pay tribute to
that you know that that whole moment for
me so you know I put together this
composition okay this is when he joins
the Nation of Islam and although in the
text Jim Hoskins doesn't mention Malcolm
X much I decided to put them in as part
of the narrative and sometimes
illustrators have to you know put in
things that the the writer might leave
but you know in the long run it all kind
of works well together but you know
you're you have to tell the story sort
of alongside the author and this is like
one of the examples where I had to do
that okay this is the prayer scene
probably my favorite in the book and
simply it's just a quiet scene and it's
just a man in prayer prior to the fight
and what I would attracted me to putting
this image together was that there's a
dichotomy here because you know fighting
is such a brutal and violent sport and
yet prayer is such a quiet thing it's
just I was just attracted to the image
of just this quiet before the storm okay
okay this is during the time where Ali
was speaking out against the war in
Vietnam and which ultimately ultimately
led him to be you're stripped of his
title and once again I put in a Howard
Cosell which you see in the alley movie
more prominently but once again in our
story he's not really mentioned so I put
him in and the book he's holding up the
book that Ali's holding up message to
the black man when I was growing up in
Harlem a lot of the black Muslims used
to walk around with this book and hold
it up and sell it just so once I saw the
book is in my in my reference I I knew I
had to put it in because it was a book
that you would see all over the place
you know as the the black Muslims at the
time we're always carrying it and
selling it this is the image of Ali as
he's gone to to Africa my idea and this
dimension unlike the others wasn't so
much to be completely realistic I wanted
an image that seemed more like a place
in Ali's mind that he went to you know
to find peace and calm within his
religion so
you know I put the composition together
kind of based on that idea that it's
it's just a place he might go in his
mind so as you can see that's why it's
composed that way with so much white
space okay
this is to come back when he comes back
to boxing after being stripped of his
title and I just wanted something
dynamic and that that really said you
know I'm back and I'm you know badder
than ever so the the fight scenes are
put together from actual photographs
that I found I altered them somehow
somewhat I started being attracted to
the idea of light you know when you see
boxing it's you know you see all the
flashlights the flashes of the flash
bulbs going on going awful all the time
and I wanted to put that in as part of
the images it's something like my dad
told me that you know in boxing
sometimes when you're there live you you
can't really see what's going on there's
so much chaos and the lights are
flashing all over the place sometimes
you're not even sure of what you may
have seen so I try to incorporate some
of that into these images where you see
the flashes going off and another thing
is that I separated all the boxing
scenes from the you know Ali's life
scenes by bordering all the boxing
scenes with like black borders to
separate the two worlds of this man you
know the boxing of a poly the boxer and
Ali the man okay okay this is a after he
defeats George Foreman for the
heavyweight champion of championship of
the world where he regains his
championship okay this is what I call
the rope-a-dope piece where he's his he
begins his down downhill spiral and
that's a Larry Holmes who you know
begins to pick Ollie apart as you can
see they're fighting he's you know
taking a beating Leon Spinks also gave
Ollie quite a pounding and those are his
corner men
bundini brown and Angelo Dundee telling
him probably that it might be time for
him to retire and at the end there you
see probably Ali contemplating that this
is brought perhaps the end of his career
and this is the last scene in a very
special one for me because Ali's holding
the torch and I remember seeing this on
television and being really moved by it
because at this point Molly as we know
is stricken with the Parkinson's
Parkinson's syndrome and he shakes
somewhat but he was able to hold the
torch there for like a moment and for me
it symbolized that this is a man who
lived so much of his life in the
spotlight and the life always was being
shown on him and here he's kind of
shining light for us and he's sort of
passing the torch you know passing the
light on to us and you know in a
symbolic way so you know I I really you
know felt really that this is a special
moment in time in Ali's career and over
here also is an image of his wife Lonnie
and their son that he that they adopted
his name Tim is not gonna help me okay
and now my editor Tim is going to read
from the book champion the Muhammad
Ali's story
you'll have to forgive me
in the book that we inserted a few of
ollies own words and and there's no way
I'll I'll do justice to that but I'll do
my best
Muhammad Ali was riding in an airplane
one time although he didn't like flying
he realized it gave him a special view
of the world he looked out the window
and down to the earth below him
I could hitchhike around the world he
thought no matter where he was someone
would know him someone would feed him
someone would give him a place to sleep
he was probably the most famous person
alive he was the heavyweight boxing
champion of the world some said he was
the greatest boxer in history everyone
said he was the fastest he was more than
that he was a new kind of boxer he lived
a clean life and had never been in jail
he was deeply religious he did not like
to hurt anybody he had helped change the
image of professional boxing from a
brutal pastime to a widely popular sport
it also shown the world that he could be
true to himself and his beliefs and
still be a winner Muhammad Ali was born
on January 17 1942 in Louisville
Kentucky he was named Cassius Marcellus
clay jr. after his father he was also
named after 19th century white
plantation owner who had freed all his
slaves and worked in slavery Cassius
Jr's great-grandfather had grown up on
that first Cassius Clay's land in
Kentucky his father was a sign painter
who loved to talk and make jokes Cassius
began to talk at a young age and also
like to make jokes not only did he tell
jokes he was a practical joker Cassius
mother Edessa clay earned money for food
by
cooking and cleaning for white people
she was very religious she read the
Bible every day and took Cassius and his
brother Rudy to church every Sunday
Cassius grew up in a time when blacks
were forced to stay apart from whites he
and Rudy had to go to a school for
blacks like most other blacks in
Louisville then the Clay's were quite
poor there was no school bus for black
kids and the Clay's didn't have enough
money to pay bus fare for both boys so
they usually had to walk to and from
school young Cassius announced that he
wanted to be rich one day but his father
told him he could never be rich because
his skin was not white although he was
basically a happy child Cassius
sometimes cried himself to sleep over
what his people had to suffer for his
12th birthday
Cassius received a shiny red bicycle it
was stolen almost as soon as he got it
angry and upset Cassius wanted to find
the thief and beat him up a policeman
told Cassius that he had better learn
how to fight first Cassius never got his
bike back he got a mission in life
instead the policemen ran a gym he
offered to teach Cassius to box Cassius
decided that boxing as a sport was more
important than fighting an anger he
learned that there were many famous
black boxers in fact there were more
black boxers in the United States than
there were white boxers boxing was a way
he could become rich and famous he went
to the gym every chance he got he ate
and drank only healthy things he began
running five miles every morning he also
started racing the bus to school Cassius
got better and better at boxing he was
very fast he had quick reflexes while he
was a junior and high while he was in
junior high in high school Cassius
fought in amateur bouts talkative and
funny he started predicting and what
round of the fight he would knock out
his
opponents he made up silly poems to tell
reporters when they interviewed him one
went like this this guy must be done
I'll stop him in one by the time he was
18 he had won 100 amateur fights these
included four national boxing
championships he had lost only eight
outs in 1960 the Summer Olympics were
held in Rome Italy
Cassius tried out and made the US
Olympic boxing team as a light
heavyweight he was so afraid of flying
that he brought his own parachute he
bought his own parachute at an army
surplus store and he wore it on the
flight to Rome in Rome Cassius met Wilma
Rudolph the young black woman from
Harlem in New York City
she was an inspiring athlete who had won
three gold medals and running at the
Olympic Games cash has had a crush on
Rudolph but she was already engaged to
another runner cash has fought for
Olympic bouts he beat fighters from
Australia Belgium Poland and Russia to
win the Olympic gold medal he was so
proud of that metal that he wore it to
bed at night back at home his father
painted the front steps of the house red
white and blue the city of Louisville
gave Cassius a hero's welcome Cassius
recited a special poem for the occasion
making reference to a figure in Roman
history who was also named Cassius he it
began to make America greatest as my
goal so I beat the Russian and I beat
the pole and for the USA won the medal
of gold Italian said you're greater than
the Cassius of old not long afterward
Cassius Clay walked into a restaurant
and ordered a glass of orange juice the
owner would not serve him because he was
black Cassius was angry and hurt he says
that the pain he felt was like having to
take punches without hitting back
after the Olympics Cassius turned
professional from then on he fought for
money
a group of local white businessmen paid
his expenses they hired a white boxing
trainer named Angelo Dundee at six feet
three inches tall and weighing almost
200 pounds Cassius was now a heavyweight
boxer he had the same quickness as when
he was 12 he also had the same loudmouth
people called him the Louisville lip and
blabbermouth
he didn't care he bragged they all must
fall in the round I call in 1964 Cassius
went up against the heavyweight champion
of the world Sonny Liston was an
ex-convict backed by the Mafia Cassius
boasted Sonny Liston is great but he'll
fall in eight secretly he was scared
Liston was older and bigger and a brutal
fighter Cassius knew he could get hurt
sports reporters were predicting that he
would be knocked out in the first round
Cassius knew the only way he could beat
Liston was to be smarter than him one of
his trainers said he would have to float
like a butterfly sting like a bee that
was the way Cassius fought Liston he
danced around the bigger man he dodged
Liston's fist round after round when he
saw that Liston was getting tired he
started throwing punches many of them
found their target
listen refused to come out of his corner
for round seven clashes Cassius Clay was
heavyweight champion of the world
raising his arms and victory shouted I
am The King I am The King then he looked
down at the reporters who had predicted
he would lose he shook his fist at them
and cried eat your words eat your words
the day after he beat Sonny Liston
Cassius Clay made a surprising
announcement he was no longer a
Christian he was now a member of the
Nation of Islam also known as the black
Muslims the nation was a militant black
organization that not only taught blacks
to be proud of themselves but also
preached that they should keep
themselves separate from whites it
claimed to follow the beliefs of the
world religion of Islam although Islam
does not preach racial separation
followers of Islam who are called
Muslims worship God in column Allah
Cassius had been interested in the black
Muslims since high school he admired
Elijah Muhammad their leader and Malcolm
X the minister whose fiery speeches had
attracted many new members to the nation
black Muslims often took new names to
honor their Muslim faith or as a sign
that they rejected their place in white
American society some like Malcolm X
used an X for their last name Cassius
Clay took a whole new Islamic name
Muhammad Ali like Muslims all over the
world Muhammad Ali prayed to Allah five
times a day he also prayed in the boxing
ring before every bout he attended
Nation of Islam temples and world Muslim
mosques wherever he could find them he
married a Muslim woman he did not have
to change his habits of eating a healthy
diet and being clean he had always lived
that way especially since she had
started boxing officials of the nation
took over management of his boxing
career but Ali kept his white trainer
Angelo Dundee over the next two years
Muhammad Ali defended his world title
several times
fighting British German Canadian and
American opponents including a rematch
with Sonny Liston he was at the top of
his form and he kept the world
heavyweight title for a total of three
years there's no telling how long he
would have remained champion
in 1967 the United States was deeply
involved in the Vietnam War US troops
were helping South Vietnam fight against
the Vietcong of North Vietnam young men
across the country were being called to
serve in the army Muhammad Ali refused
to join the army saying keep asking me
no matter how long on the war in Vietnam
I sing this song I ain't got no quarrel
with them Vietcong the United States had
outlawed racial segregation while Ali
was heavyweight champion of the world
nevertheless blacks were still denied
many opportunities it would be a long
time before they enjoyed equality with
whites Ali said he did not believe in
fighting for freedom for other people
when his own people were not free
members of the Nation of Islam did not
serve in the military in those days they
did not get involved in politics or even
vote Muhammad Ali said it was against
his religion to join the army
the United States government charged him
with the crime of refusing military
service and prosecuted him for draft
evasion
Ali was sentenced to pay a fine and
spend five years in jail he was allowed
to remain free while he appealed the
verdict to a higher court but he was
banned from boxing and his title was
taken away from him most people believed
he was guilty the ban was a terrible
blow to Muhammad Ali's career he did not
have a professional boxing match for
nearly four years as other heavyweight
boxers won and lost the championship Ali
insisted that the title was still his
until someone beat him in the ring he
believed that he remained the true
champion Ali spent his years of Exile
speaking out against the Vietnam War
during this difficult time he drew
strength from his faith Islam had helped
him overcome other challenges in the
past it helped him conquer his fear of
flying
and had enabled him to take his first
trip to Africa where there are many
Muslims Ali learned that unlike the
Nation of Islam world Islam is not
anti-white all true believers are
accepted as had Malcolm X before him he
would one day break away from the
radical nation of islam and devote
himself to world islam eventually the
Supreme Court the highest court in the
land recognized Ali's devotion to his
faith and ruled that he had been treated
unfairly American citizens have the
right to refuse military service because
of their religion while he did not have
to pay a fine or go to jail
Ali was nearly 29 years old when he
returned to boxing he had lost some of
his speed some people believed his days
as a winner in the boxing ring were over
Ali proved them wrong winning his first
fight against Jerry quarry by a knockout
in the third round by the time he went
up against Argentina Argentinian boxer
Oscar Bonavena he was writing poems
again his poem about the bond Avena
fight ended with before around 9 is out
the referee will jump and shout that's
all folks this turkey is out this time
his prediction did not come true it took
him 15 rounds to knockout Bonavena on
March 8th 1971 Ali went up against the
world heavyweight champion Joe Frazier
Ali was almost knocked out and the
judges awarded the win to Frazier it was
the first loss of his professional
career Ali accepted the defeat but he
declared that he wanted to fight Frazier
again three years passed and many of
Ali's matches that lasted much longer
than they had when he was younger he had
his jaw broken in a fight against Ken
Norton for his second loss meanwhile Joe
Frazier lost the heavyweight title to
George Foreman finally the 2x champions
Ali and Frazier had their rematch this
time Ali outboxed Frazier the
judges awarded him the win now Ali could
go up against Foreman for the
heavyweight boxing crown by 1974 Foreman
had won all 24 of his professional bouts
by knockout
Ali trained harder than he ever had
before the fight was staged in the
African nation of Zaire and was billed
as the rumble in the jungle it was a
proud moment for all of black Africa
which was fighting against white South
Africa's support of racism Ali hoped Ali
hoped it would be a proud moment for him
he knew it was going to be a tough fight
Foreman was younger and stronger
nevertheless Ali was faster and more
experienced he knocked down Foreman in
the eighth round and the referee counted
amount after seven long years Muhammad
Ali had won his title back
during those years Ali had also won
respect most Americans had come to
believe that the United States was wrong
to fight in Vietnam they admired Ali for
standing up to the government they also
understood that he was sincere in his
religious faith he had not tried to
escape from the draft by using religion
as an excuse he remained a devoted
follower of world Islam Ali said many
times he would know when it was time to
retire he wanted to leave boxing before
he was seriously injured he believed
that his style of boxing protected him
as he put it in one of his poems in the
ring I can stay until I'm old and gray
because I know how to hit and dance away
his style depended on speed however and
he was slowing down he had to learn how
to take a punch although he won many
bouts he was injured several times his
third and final bout in 1975 against Joe
Frazier in the Philippines known as the
Thrilla in Manilla
is considered by many to be the greatest
boxing match of all time
Ali won but at a great cost
he took nearly 440 punches during that
one fight in 1978 after defending his
title successfully ten times he lost it
to Leon Spinks he regained the title by
beating Spinks seven months later and
became the first boxer to win the
heavyweight championship three times he
then announced his retirement
sadly against the wishes of his friends
and family he returned to the ring for
two more bouts in 1980 1981 and lost
both at 39 years old he was beginning to
suffer from brain damage he looked the
same but he sometimes had trouble
speaking his reflexes were slowing and
his movements could be stiff boxing had
given him an incurable condition called
Parkinson's syndrome does not threaten
his life or affect his intelligence but
it does steadily erode his control over
his own body since retiring from the
boxing ring Muhammad Ali has enjoyed his
life although he doesn't live there now
his heart has always stayed in his
hometown of Louisville Kentucky where
his brother Rudy still lives
Ali intends to build a Muhammad Ali
Center to train young boys in the sport
that gave him so much Ali is close to
his fourth wife Lonnie and to his nine
children he was not around much when the
older children were growing up so he
especially enjoys playing with the
youngest Asad who whom he and Lonnie
adopted Assad and the many people who
visit enjoy the magic tricks that Ali
does to entertain them
Ali remains a devout Muslim and prays
five times a day he considers himself
the world's goodwill ambassador and
appears in public quite often although
he rarely speaks in 1996 Muhammad Ali he
made a surprise appearance at the Summer
Olympics in Atlanta Georgia he was the
final bearer of the torch that lights
the Olympic flame and opens the game's
his arms shook as he held the symbol of
international sporting competition no
one had expected
and the crowd in the stadium and the
billions of television watchers
throughout the world cheered with love
and respect
Ali was as much a symbol himself as was
the torch he was a symbol of strength
and skill of courage and pride he was a
man who broke down barriers and who
brought people together a champion in
more ways than one thank you
okay well thank you Tim for reading the
book at this point I'm gonna ask if
there are any questions you have to go
to the mic and then
in your own opinion do you think
Muhammad Ali is the best boxer of all
time well in my opinion I think he is
especially after doing this book I just
you know I I have great admiration for
him however if you asked my dad who's
like the real boxing fanatic in the
family he still feels that Sugar Ray
Robinson is the ban so and my dad and I
always go back and forth about that but
I believe he is and in a fight between
those two who do you think Riley of
course you float like a butterfly sting
like a bee okay thank you are you have
two guys you guys have to go to the mic
good okay
you plan on um illustrating another book
about Muhammad Ali in the future another
book on Muhammad Ali unless you write it
and we don't have any in the works
do you have any ideas maybe as he gets
older or something like that yeah oh no
though this just one but now goodbye
what book was the most fun for you that
you illustrated the most fun well I
would say champion only in that I'm
getting closer and closer to combining
my love of comic books with you know my
love of picture books you know I did
write grandma's records and illustrated
that and that was a you know a lot of
fun but it was very difficult because I
had to deal with it as though someone
else wrote it and it's just a whole
other you know sensibility this one was
just pure fun a lot of agony but a lot
of fun are you gonna do a comic book
ever did you ask me that before no there
are plenty of guys out there that are
like really good at that I think my my
future lies in just combining the two
you know disciplines and incidentally
everyone this is a Ryan Rossi who's his
mom is responsible for setting this
whole thing up so I just want to give my
man a nice shout out here
how long did it take to illustrate
champion oh that's a good question
it took about eight months maybe even a
little longer from start to finish it's
the longest project I ever worked on it
took a long time did you think you could
have finished it like sooner yeah no way
in fact I still need it more time when I
was finished it was my editor Tim who
started pressing me to get it closer to
a finish you know thank you okay
did you ever actually meet Muhammad Ali
no we were trying to set something up
but he was contracted through the movie
that was in production at the time to
appear only in conjunction with the film
so they kind of extras out of the of the
deal
but we really wanted to meet him and I
had a lot of questions for him I still
expect someday to meet him not yet
anyone you said that you got into
illustrating from the storybooks that
your mother read you and a comics that
you read is there anything in particular
that you kind of developed a technique
from or any particular artist oh yeah
definitely from the comic books via
paneling I love that stuff you know
because it moves the story along and
that's what I felt was missing from
picture books you know in picture books
usually is just one image per page and I
felt that you know the panels that you
see in comic books are almost more
natural and more movie like and I'm a
big movie fan so I hopefully have
answered your question how did you come
to admire Muhammad Ali well the thing is
that you know Muhammad Ali was always
there from Marillion I've always heard
his name you know when it was still
Cassius Clay since my dad was always
watching here the fights on television
back then they were on a wide world of
sports so everything it wasn't it's not
like today that you have to do
pay-per-view and all that the fights
were always on television either Wide
World of Sports would show them later
but there was never a time in my life
when I wasn't aware of you know Muhammad
Ali or Cassius Clay you know because of
my dad did you learn anything new when
you're doing the project oh yeah
I I have just a greater and deeper
respect for the man now you know more
than just yeah I see them as more than
just a boxer in fact you know I see him
more as a hero
you know a champion then I and I do it
but then I do it uh just a boxer
do you think anyone would fight like
Muhammad Ali in the future
well Sugar Ray Leonard came pretty close
to in getting that style down but he
sort of fell short but I'm hoping you
know he made the sport really exciting
you know with his old razzle-dazzle
you know style and all the trash talk I
mean you realize that he's sort of the
father of trash talk like what you see
the rock and those other wrestlers do
that today that's all from Muhammad Ali
migrant my grandfather is used to be a
fan of Muhammad Ali but now he's a fan
of externa dead who do you think is the
best boxer right now
Wow right now well I too like Felix
Trinidad
he's from the part of Puerto Rico that
my father's from so I've been watching
his career pretty closely
so I guess Trinidad and you know I still
have some hopes for Tyson if he ever
decides to come back or you know can get
his act together but you know I'm always
looking for whoever's on the horizon
some someone new I'm from Puerto Rico
till um what part of Puerto Rico or your
parents warning okay this is a great
question
Fahad Lepanto Tito my father's from
there and my mother's from San Jose my
grandmother is well most of my family
I'm seeing horn San Juan well Santos a
is pretty close to that one yeah so do
you speak Spanish no oh you should learn
you should learn thank you
do you enjoy what writing or
illustrating books better I think I
prefer the illustrating more than
writing what my approach to writing is
so much like illustrating I have to
write stuff out and then I I write it
over again and over and over again it's
it's not something I do as well as is
drawing I'm just it just flows easier to
just draw it out for me
Oh as a kid what was the first thing you
wrote about well at first I would retell
like the stories in like the picture
books that my mom would bring home she
the one that was my favorite was one
called a lollipop party and you know I
made my own version was like the ice
cream party you know it changed you know
this this snow ice it's like a snow cone
we call it B d'água you know so I was
like the p-dog wa party and then after
that I started doing my own comic books
and those were based on the exploits of
my my friends and cousins when we went
to a junior high school together and got
into all sorts of trouble so I I started
documenting that in these the series
that I created called the sunshine boys
of Joan of Arc junior high school 1:18
so those were the stories what's the
hardest part of writing for you all of
it
the easiest I'll start with that the
easier this coming up with the story
but like I said I write things out the
first time out and then I rewrite it and
then rewrite it and get it to know it so
getting it just right so it sounds right
to me probably is the hardest you know
so it takes me a lot of time you know to
kind of rewrite things and get it you
know to sound just right but the story
part that comes you know instantly you
know making up the story has always been
easy for me and I think because I've
always you know looked at film and read
so many comic books
um what age were you again when you
started on actually drawing and writing
well I started drawing at an early age
at about four or five years old I was
already drawing you know once I started
you know seeing the picture books that
my mom brought home so I was always
scribbling and drawing now don't get the
idea that my drawings look like you know
Michelangelo it would really crude
drawings it wasn't until later that I
started developing you know a more
realistic style yeah what age did you
start like really getting good about 11
or 12 I would say yeah I at one point I
was like the most famous artist in the
school when I started doing my little
series based on my my cousins and I in
junior high school but then I went to
the High School of Art and Design and
everybody there was better than me so
you know it was a little devastating but
eventually you know III I I snapped out
of it and started picking up some steam
Thanks what's your favorite book or
comic book series the Green Arrow Green
Lantern series back when Neal Adams was
doing it I don't know if you're a comic
book fan I remember Neal Adams work at
all no but that the Neal Adams had a way
of drawing comic books but he was like
his thought was really realistic more so
than the other guys like Salva scheme'
maybe so I started following Neal Adams
his career you know so like whatever he
would put out you know I would buy that
you know like when he did the x-men I
did then I bought that entire series
another comic book series of that that
followed was the spirit by Will Eisner
because his storytelling seems so much
like watching a movie that I was drawn
to that you know so I started collecting
you know the spirit comic books as well
which were like they were black and
white printed the back of white
um in those times when Muhammad Ali I'm
heading had lost and he got really I'm
injured
and sometimes if he got injured badly
and in your opinion do you think he may
have felt like I'm trying me another
match or just I just felt like he was
just gonna stop with any but then the
thug Friday we probably came back about
doing another match okay you said a lot
there was the question if he should have
stopped sooner or continued fighting is
that me yeah I'm of the belief that he
should have stopped sooner than then
when he did you know probably the
Muhammad Ali that you would know today
would be a whole lot different than than
the one that you know it's out there now
are you going to write another book and
if you are I'm what's it gonna be about
yes I'm in the process of writing
another book it's actually a prequel to
grandma's records but it's a slow
process for me and I'm also working on
other books that I'm illustrating so
it'll be wants to get based on my
grandmother and I which was a special
time for me
so yeah look for it maybe in a two to
three years okay
do you consider the boxers of Muhammad
Ali's time better than the boxers today
that's a tricky question because with it
I started watching all the fight footage
I noticed that the action seemed a lot
slower at times and the reaction that
we're used to today and unless I guess
we put those you know the two boxers
like let's say someone like you know
like Mike Tyson in the ring with someone
you know such as Muhammad Ali you really
won't know but there was a magic in the
the older boxes that the younger boxers
don't seem to to capture but yeah unless
you see the fight you really can't tell
that's way I feel about it
how wasn't where he used to live how was
it yeah Spanish halogen um it was great
Spanish Harlem is a community you know a
lot of stores a lot of people everyone
sort of knows each other most of the
people in Spanish Harlem the park that I
grew up in 115th Street Madison Avenue
they're all from Puerto Rico the same
part of Puerto Rico so the a lot of them
know each other going way back I mean it
was a great place Harlem also a great
place it's very different you know it
for us because we were sort of the
outsiders and you know we gradually you
know assimilated into that community
that answer your question
yep okay were you ever had any Pok Singh
matches me yeah no no I I think in my
whole life I probably have maybe just
one big fight in the 6th grade that it
wasn't even much of a fight we just
rolled around the playground all over
the place until the principal came out
is separated us I'm a lover not a
fighter were you born to tell him to
draw or or did you get taught to Joe uh
I was not born drawing at all like I
said when I would although I loved to
draw it didn't really look like much it
was through actually good teachers and
you know trying to get copying things
out of books and magazines that I really
got better but you know I was not born
Beatle drawing that at all and what did
you major in in college uh illustration
yeah do you admire any other two people
like Muhammad Ali do I admire any other
people like Muhammad Ali any other
people
tons of people but most of the people I
admire tend to be people in the arts you
know either jazz musicians or other
artists I think Muhammad Ali is probably
like the only real sports bigger
that that's in my list and that's
probably that's probably what surprised
my editors so much are they they weren't
aware that that I was into Muhammad Ali
at all because I'm always talking about
jazz I'm talking about art all the time
and I don't really talk much about about
sports I have two questions my first one
is um what made Muhammad Ali change his
religion he if you saw the movies or
movies he came in contact with Malcolm X
early on but he was still in Miami prior
to the Sonny Liston fight and he
listened to Malcolm speeches that he
would give at the local mosque and I
guess you know he liked what he what he
heard and he was drawn to you know the
whole idea of you know the Nation of
Islam at that time but you got to
understand that the context in which all
that happened was you know there was a
lot of racism in America at the time you
know a lot of suffering you know so you
can almost understand why at that time
you know someone might be drawn to the
you know the messages in in Malcolm X's
speeches and um that question is oh do
you know what Muhammad Ali's record was
when he lost to Joe Frazier do you know
how many fights you won I would defer to
a Tim for that what you know what we
were working on the project we were like
Muhammad Ali experts but I've since
illustrated another book and I'm
currently working on another so you know
it starts to fade in your mind you
should have caught us about six or seven
months ago sorry have you illustrated
any book covers that you haven't written
for like you ever you're involved with
the book just the book cover
um well yeah you're asking about the
book covers that I did yes the title
page yeah I did I I think I pretty much
did like 300 images before I started
doing my first before I even did my
first picture book I don't know if
you're familiar with the encyclopedia
brown series I did all the book covers
for that I've done
book covers on just about every topic
journey to Joburg chain of fire or two
of the like more popular books that it
was it did the cover and some interior
illustrations for tons of stuff
amazon.com just punch my name is it'll
all come up almost anchor down please
okay I want to thank you for being a
great audience
Eric Velasquez is the illustrator of
champion the story of Muhammad Ali it's
published by Walker & Company online